[Aplausos]
[Música]
venezuela es un país del que se habla
hasta la saciedad en todos los medios de
comunicación de fuera pero muy poquito
en los de dentro por ejemplo los que
veáis este vídeo desde españa ya sabéis
que el colapso económico de venezuela y
la crisis política que sufre este país
está en boca de todos los políticos de
madrid yo no estoy de acuerdo con muchas
cosas que hace el gobierno de venezuela
por una situación de extrema gravedad
venezuela para venezuela y hablar laude
por ud y estamos ahora en escuela sin
embargo si entráis en la página web de
una de las televisiones públicas
venezolanas como por ejemplo telesur
encontrareis noticias de todos los
países del mundo
- de venezuela
para que os hagáis una idea mientras
preparaba este vídeo eche un vistazo a
la portada de este medio
y encontré 29 noticias destacadas de las
cuales solamente 5 se referían a su
propio país
[Música]
en este momento no hay nadie que ponga
en duda que venezuela pasa por toda una
crisis humanitaria según un estudio
realizado por tres universidades de este
país el venezolano a medio ha perdido
entre 8 y 10 kilos de peso medio debido
a la escasez de alimentos lo que no está
tan claro es el grado de responsabilidad
que tiene su gobierno cómo está
respondiendo nicolás maduró a esta
situación
para muchos políticos y analistas
venezuela es ya oficialmente una
dictadura cosas como encarcelar a los
políticos de la oposición o intentar
disolver el parlamento han desencadenado
reacciones diplomáticas al más alto
nivel y el retiro del embajador de perú
en venezuela fue respaldado por el
parlamento sin embargo nos sobran
quienes mantienen que venezuela sigue
siendo un país democrático incluso que
nicolás maduro está defendiendo el país
de un golpe de estado y la pregunta es
quién de los dos tiene razón podemos
decir que venezuela es una dictadura o
es una exageración hoy vamos a responder
a esta pregunta pero antes vamos a
conocer la historia que está contando el
gobierno de maduro
golpe de estado de quien según nicolás
maduro la crisis venezolana se resume en
una conspiración de eeuu y todos sus
aliados para acabar con la revolución
bolivariana la élite imperialista que
desprecia a nuestro pueblo y que tiene
como objetivo la destrucción de la
independencia de la democracia y de la
vida en paz de nuestra patria ellos han
decidido han decidido activar planes
para la desestabilización global de la
sociedad de color ya se lo que estáis
pensando pero vamos a asumir que esta
teoría tiene algún sentido en este caso
la burguesía internacional no sólo
querría desestabilizar la economía
venezolana sino también derrocar a su
gobierno y eso explicaría el miedo que
tiene nicolás maduró a un golpe de
estado pero espera su momento porque
antes de continuar deberíamos definir
que es un golpe de estado
[Música]
un golpe de estado se define como la
toma de poder repentina y violenta
mediante un grupo de poder normalmente
el ejército y cuál es el problema aquí
pues que el ejército de venezuela es
completamente afín a nicolás maduro
incluso el propio hugo chávez había
estado en las fuerzas armadas es más a
diferencia de otros países como españa
donde la ley prohíbe que los militares
se metan en política en venezuela hay
varios ministros que vienen de las
fuerzas armadas aquí tenemos al
almirante meléndez rivas ministra de
presidencia o al general marco torres
ministro de alimentación en total un
tercio de los ministros venezolanos son
militares
dicho esto quien podría dar ese supuesto
golpe de estado al gobierno de nicolás
maduro
[Música]
pues efectivamente los partidos
políticos de la oposición el problema
que ninguno de ellos tiene ninguna
relación con el ejército es decir que
tanto enrique capriles como leopoldo
lópez como todos los principales líderes
de la oposición venezolana son
empresarios o políticos de carrera y no
tienen ninguna relación ni con las
fuerzas armadas ni con ningún grupo
paramilitar que les pueda apoyar
pese a todo esto el gobierno de nicolás
maduro insiste en que son estos
políticos los que están detrás de la
violencia callejera como os podéis
imaginar en un país donde la gente llega
a pagar el sueldo de un día entero solo
por comprar un kilo de cebollas es
completamente normal que haya protestas
en la calle nos parece sumarle a eso el
hecho de que caracas es la ciudad más
violenta de toda latinoamérica y
entenderéis porque muchas de estas
manifestaciones terminan así
[Aplausos]
[Música]
sin embargo para el gobierno de
venezuela los enfrentamientos entre
policía y manifestantes son el resultado
de la propaganda de la oposición en
septiembre de 2015 tres meses antes de
las elecciones legislativas venezolanas
el gobierno a restaba a leopoldo lópez
uno de los principales líderes de los
partidos de la oposición la acusación
aseguraba que este hombre estaba
incitando a la violencia con
declaraciones como esta
no tienes las agallas para meterte preso
o esperas órdenes de la habana te lo
digo la verdad está de nuestro lado pero
el auténtico punto de inflexión vino más
tarde concretamente en diciembre de 2015
en estos días venezuela celebró
elecciones parlamentarias y los partidos
de la oposición a nicolás maduró
agrupados en lo que llaman la mesa de
unidad democrática mud por sus siglas
ganaron las elecciones al partido del
gobierno por más de 2 millones de votos
en un principio la reacción del
mandatario venezolano fue la que cabría
esperar en cualquier gobierno
democrático a reconocer estos resultados
adversos a aceptarlos pero que es lo
primero que hace esta asamblea nacional
con mayoría anti maduro pues intentan
convocar una moción de censura para
organizar unas elecciones presidenciales
anticipadas en las que puedan derrocar a
nicolás maduro y aquí es cuando el
presidente y su camarilla cambian
radicalmente de opinión cuando digo ha
triunfado la guerra económica es porque
el terror que le metieron a la vida
económica de nuestro pueblo y me vio a
un porcentaje importante y viró la
corriente durante estos últimos dos años
las relaciones entre maduro y la
asamblea nacional han sido absolutamente
tensas e incluso el gobierno de
venezuela ha intentado disolver la
asamblea nacional asegurando que tres de
los parlamentarios habían ganado las
elecciones de forma fraudulenta
por supuesto ni siquiera el tribunal
superior de venezuela acertó esta
versión y eso explica que este 1 de mayo
de 2017
nicolás maduro haya tomado la decisión
final el punto de no retorno lo convocó
el poder constituyente originario
para lograr la paz que necesita la
república para derrotar el golpe
fascista y para que sea el pueblo con su
soberanía quien imponga la paz la
armonía el diálogo nacional verdadero en
otras palabras maduro quiere construir
un nuevo parlamento que se encargue de
redactar la nueva constitución
venezolana este nuevo texto le daría
poderes plenos al presidente y
convertiría a venezuela oficialmente en
una dictadura y os preguntaréis va a
convocar elecciones para crear este
nuevo parlamento lo cierto es que en
teoría sí sí que va a convocar
elecciones pero también es cierto que
desde el año 2015 hay decenas de
políticos de la oposición venezolana en
la cárcel según el gobierno todos ellos
son unos golpistas así que ya me
contaréis como pueden ser unas
elecciones democráticas donde no hay
partidos de oposición pero eso no es
todo porque os preguntaréis qué ocurre
con los medios de comunicación
los defensores de nicolás maduro
que venezuela tiene libertad de
expresión pero es eso cierto ahora mismo
lo vamos a ver
a la libertad de expresión en venezuela
según la constitución venezolana la
libertad de expresión es un derecho
fundamental y es cierto que existen
varios periódicos que apoyan al gobierno
pero sabéis cuál es su problema que no
tienen papel para imprimirlos tal cual
en venezuela- la importación y venta de
papel es un monopolio regulado por el
estado y eso explica que periódicos
antichavistas y anti maduro como el
nacional hayan tenido que reducir no
solamente su tirada sino también su
tamaño o que por ejemplo otros muchos
periódicos que eran de difusión diaria
hayan pasado a ser semanales
[Música]
y os preguntaréis qué pasa con internet
lo cierto es que en este ámbito el
gobierno de maduro tiene poderes totales
y absolutos para bloquear cualquier
página web por absurda que parezca
habéis oído hablar alguna vez de bit.ly
se trata de una página web en la que tú
metes un enlace y te lo hace más corto
para que lo puedas utilizar en twitter
pues atentos
los links acortados de bit.ly están
prohibidos en venezuela como os podéis
imaginar y billy está prohibido también
lo están muchas otras páginas que son
más críticas con el gobierno como la cnn
infobae o dollar today todas estas webs
son inaccesibles desde venezuela a no
ser que utilices una conexión próxima y
por supuesto a todo esto le tenemos que
añadir las encarcelaciones de más de 40
periodistas críticos con el gobierno o
incluso aún peor
al menos seis tuiteros se encuentran
detenidos en venezuela por opinar habéis
oído bien detenidos no juzgados es decir
gente que está en la cárcel pero sin
duda alguna el medio más castigado por
el gobierno de maduro ha sido la
televisión durante décadas
caracas fue algo así como el hollywood
de las telenovelas latinoamericanas eso
que en españa conocemos como los
culebrones y que ven nuestras abuelas
después de comer y mi corazón
pues bien casi todas estas series se
producían en venezuela- con lo que ya os
podéis imaginar que en este país siempre
han tenido muchísimas cadenas de
televisión privadas y lógicamente muchas
de ellas tienen una línea editorial
contraria a los intereses de nicolás
maduró una vez más la constitución de
venezuela reconoce por un lado la
libertad de expresión en las
televisiones privadas pero por el otro
existe otra ley que obliga a todas las
cadenas de televisión a emitir los
discursos de nicolás maduró y no os
creáis que hablamos de un programa al
año maduros sale varias veces por semana
y todas las televisiones tanto públicas
como privadas están obligadas a
interrumpir su programación para ofrecer
el sermón del presidente que muchas
veces se alarga durante horas y a todo
esto le tenemos que sumar operaciones
comerciales tan sospechosas como ésta
[Música]
televisión venezolana globovisión y
anuncian una nueva línea editorial del
centro esta noticia es de antes de que
nicolás maduro fuera presidente en la
época de hugo chávez globovisión era una
de las televisiones más críticas con el
gobierno en 2013 la propiedad cambió de
manos y sus nuevos dueños tenían
conexiones directas con el gobierno
chavista
nada más llegar esta nueva dirección
corporativa despide a la mitad de la
plantilla y de repente globovisión pasa
a ser una televisión de centro este
solamente es un ejemplo pero hay
muchísimos más
dicho esto solo cabe hacerse una
pregunta en qué se diferencian nicolás
maduró de cualquier dictador en el que
podamos pensar de verdad alguien puede
afirmar que venezuela sigue siendo una
democracia podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios mientras
tanto si queréis entender cuáles son las
razones económicas que han llevado a
venezuela al colapso
haced clic en este vídeo
[Música]
y por cierto os tenemos que dar las
gracias a todos los que nos estáis
haciendo donaciones voluntarias a
nuestra cuenta de paypal nunca os las
hemos pedido pero nos suponen una ayuda
enorme para poder continuar con visual
política e incluso sacar nuevos
proyectos de los que os informaremos
próximamente así que muchísimas gracias
a todos porque vosotros lo estáis
haciendo posible si os han gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]
[Aplausos]